Recall also the related idea of neuroplasticity from the brain lesson. Neurons
grow and develop when they're used and stimulated by experience. And of course,
our favorite, Hebb's Law. Neurons that fire together, wire together. Our brain
neural growth are shaped by experience especially in the first few years of
life. Neural growth is rampant in the womb and during the first year or two of
life. But not all of this growth is happening just because of experience. Some
of it happens just because we have such big, complex brains and they need to
develop. All of this random neural growth ultimately does have a price to pay.
These random neural connections that are not stimulated and strengthened due to
experience end up dying off. Or in other words, they're pruned. And this is
know as neural pruning.